[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about Justin's fate in the final
season out getting terms this video
includes season 8 footage leaks and
leaked photos are spoiling John's path
through his final episodes that's why
the title includes confirmed spoilers so
you've been warned
beside leaks in this video you'll also
hear a few theories and predictions
about just now in season 8 okay let's
just jump into it in first episode of
the final season we'll see Jon Snow
arriving home at Winterfell as the long
night comes bearing down on Westeros Jon
Snow and Danny are heading north to
prepare for the great war with their
crews arrival at Winterfell pretty much
all the main characters will be at the
same place at the same time and it only
makes sense for some of them to finally
reunite and share a couple of words when
John arrives at Winterfell he'll have a
heartbreaking reunion with his family
with sin sari and bran as well as with
his friend Sam and his Darvill ghost
firstly Jon sensor Union has been
confirmed to take place in the season 8
premiere with the season 8 first look
teaser image we got to see a clip of
January night amid sister and Lady of
Winterfell Sansa some of the fans
claimed the hug share doesn't feel all
that warm and we should worry about
senses attentions some are even going
that far to claim that this clip rematch
in sense as possible betrayal over John
Snow this in my opinion is not the case
has already had an opportunity told 12
Jon in season seven that the northern
Lords were complaining that the king in
the north should have stayed in the
north with Lord lover and Lord Royce
even going that far to propose Sansa to
take power in the absence of her brother
Jon if she wanted to sensible that
already betrayed Jon instead she
insisted that jon is their true ruler
with doing what he believes is right for
their people and that she is merely his
regent so sensible change our theory in
my opinion is not plausible at all the
reason why censor may be glaring over
Jon shoulder turned out to be Danny just
as we here on fire and blood expected
and there will be some tension between
sense and Jon's new lover having in mind
that sense of back in the second episode
of the seventh season said that Danny
doesn't want to help the north but
rather wants to conquer it it's fair to
assume that sense of and not accept
Danny as well as Jon did or at least not
at first
as Danny said herself in the season 7
finale she's not hearing nor
to conquer it better to save it and it's
something the north Lords will see for
themselves in the very beginning of the
final season sensible see for yourself
who tential is and what her true
intentions are and eventually truly
accept her and they will get along since
I might also say to both John and Danny
they're risking their lives and losing
one of three dragons in order to protic
Windsor said that the army of the Dead
Israel was both stupid and pointless mo
as we say losing one dragon Cersei will
never help her own enemies in war no
matter it's against the night King this
is something censor knows because out of
all of them she's the one who spend the
most time with Cersei and she's the only
one who fully understand that search
they would never provide a living savage
troops that she's likely to lose in the
great war and therefore weaken our
position on the Iron Throne as the queen
of the Seven Kingdoms since I will also
warn Danny that Cersei will take
advantage of the war between the living
and the dead which serves they confirm
itself in the season 7 finale that's a
side of sense I'm looking for and hoping
to see in the final season anyways it's
not only Jon and Sansa who will finally
Reno at Winterfell it's also John and
Arya the most anticipated game of
Thrones raining he'll be made into
scissoring in between those two since
the very first season we'll be hoping
for Jon Arryn in season 7 but it will
just miss each other however they will
finally reunite in the first episode
john loves and cares for all his
siblings but John and Arya have a unique
bond which the show made sure to remind
us of just before the actual rain in
takes place with Sansa mentioning to
Arya how happy John will be when his
Caesar John denarii over very close
growing up
it was John who secretly head needle
forged for Arya encouraging her to
become who she always wanted to be a
warrior it's only fitting for them to
see each other again before the great
war begins I cannot wait to see these
two fighting together in his net king's
army John Italian still sword then are a
bit Valyrian steel dagger
jonald arena with brain as well it's
been a long time since John seen bran
but brain did see John in season four
when he was travelling north of the wall
he saw John from afar fighting the
mutineers too many Lord Commander brain
is beside Sam and Howland Reed the only
person who knows Joshua lineage and who
witnessed John's birth even though he's
been waiting the whole season to reveal
to John the truth I don't think he will
reveal to John in their first meeting
the reason being too many people around
them brennon semi likely wait for
private moment with
rather than revealing such an important
life-changing information to him in
front of everyone and I think wet brain
might not even be the one to reveal the
truth in I think it will rather be
Howland Reed who will in the final
season finally appear supporting House
Stark and living in a great war against
the dead and will John the truth the
night King has brought down the wall and
is marching towards Winterfell to attack
it almost all the living in Westeros on
the other hand is also marching towards
Winterfell to defend it
I don't think house raid will be the
only house beside house lane is turned
out to join the great war and I don't
think we've seen all of Howland Reed I
think he will finally appear in the
current timeline and play his role and
imagine upon arriving in Winterfell
beside reuniting this family General
Serena's friend Sam who also knows the
truth behind true lineage John and Sam
will see each other for the very first
time since Janice killed and resurrected
Sam might even be the one to reveal to
John his true parentage
while Holland could confirm these same
statements to John with some evidence if
John tells them about what happened to
him in the Nights Watch death and
resurrection it's possible I decided
revealing to Jon that he's a Targaryen
samurai to also proclaim Jana's were
high in the season 7 premiere show
pointing out that the bogey Lee picked
up and began reading was a book about
the long night while the exact part she
was reading was about the prophecy of
azor Ahai I already made a video
regarding which character might be this
prophesied Savior but John's son of Ice
and Fire since more and more to be the
Lord shows it anyways upon finding out
about John Shu parentage in season 7
which basic confirms that he is a Song
of Ice and Fire
and upon finding out about John's death
and resurrection the final season it's
quite possible it's a meal proclaim John
as were high a hero that was reborn amid
smokin salt a hero that will build the
flaming sword to stand against the
others and if he falls the world falls
weddin it's going to be very interesting
to see John's reaction like his father
Rhaegar I think general eventually
accept his part in the prophecy and in
the Great War that's all I'm going to
say about it for now I also believe that
the book about the long night that
Gilley was reading in season 7 premiere
will resurface in the final season which
will likely lead Sam - once again as
bran if he is able to look back in time
but his time even deeper in the past to
see what exactly happened the last time
the White Walkers came for the living
this is how Sam and brain will play a
huge role in the final season as they
will help John and Danny strategy
further fighting in the night King and
his army of the Dead this whole problem
well quite a few flashbacks where we'll
learn a bit more about why Walker
scenario motivations now the jack has
reunited with his family and friends he
has one more important reunion to face
the one with his direwolf it's been
confirmed that ghost will finally return
in season 8 all of us enjoy the dragons
but their walls have also been a huge
part of game Jones especially of the
stark children we have not seen ghost
ever since Jon's resurrection for all of
you wondering where ghosts even is he's
a winner fell the showrunners confirmed
that ghost a demon are felt it's and Sam
and John left to meet Danny a
Dragonstone during season seven instead
of goals the showrunners decided to
fulfill their long awaited wish of
having an undead bear for the final
season however the game mattress
production has much higher budget and
ghosts will finally be back at it John
will arena if it goes early on in the
season and I'm sure we'll see more of
him in the following episodes especially
in the battle for Winterfell that is
taking place in episode 3 however while
there will be a few moments of
heartbreaking reunions between John his
family and friends there will be no time
for much small talk because Winterfell
is already preparing for the war even
though John is unaware of the fact that
the nat king and his army are marching
south of the wall Bren already informed
everyone in Winterfell as he himself
through his vocal ramus witness the
moment with the night King destroyed a
large portion of the wall allowing his
army to march south upon being informed
about this huge news next thing we will
see meaner fallacies it was soon to be
Jon having an urgent meeting the
majority of the northern Lords and his
allies at the Great Hall in order to
discuss their strategy and defenses
jungle summer in the mid season learn of
his show lineage better to say more
brain or maybe even through Howland Reed
once John learns he's a Targaryen which
basically means he and Danny are related
as Rhaegar is his father and Danny's
Rhaegar sister the ironies of harem dan
is carrying his child
it has been highlighted numerous times
during the season that Dany believes she
can no longer have children because of a
prophecy that was told her by miramos
during the season 1 finale the prophecy
tells and the Sun rises in the West and
sets in the east when the Seas go dry
and the mountains blow in the wind like
leaves in your room quickens again and
you bear a living child and he will
return and not before
even though Danny does believe in his
prophecy as John pointed out himself it
may not be entirely true this shown
least so many people were talking about
the in his ability to help children in
it seems that it seems like John and
Danny having a baby is not even
questionable
I was rather foreshadowed there and
talked to Danny about her plan for
succession Danny talked with John our
dragons are the only children she'll
ever have and even Jorah talked to John
about John's future child just as John
stated it's highly possible that the
witch was not being honest today which
along with all those foreshadows might
mean that the season finale brings more
surprises than we hoped for
if Danny truly is pregnant that's
definitely something John will find out
earlier in the season the only problem
is Danny getting pregnant is another
theory that's been floating around for
quite some time if then it surely got
pregnant could she die in childbirth
we know that her own mother died giving
birth to her John's mother also died
giving birth to him which puts then in
dangerous situation how I see John
learning this is through Danny of course
and probably in the crypts of NFL will
John then reel to the any issue
parentage or not it's also something
that interests me I think this might
take place as early as episode 2 of the
final season it was revealed that
episode 2 will see the return of the
crypts of NFL which was being filmed on
its long-standing location at Shane's
castle it was also reported there will
be a scene between two leading cast
members in crypts and they will be
discussing Ned Stark's death in this
particular scene so it's basically
something similar to what we already saw
in season 7 when censing re-discuss Nets
death as well as the statue my guess is
that this time it will be John and Danny
discussing it and it might be before or
after Danny reveals to John that she's
pregnant with his child since its
episode two one episode before the night
King arrives at Manor foul it's highly
possible that this is the episode in
which Holland appears to these troops
and supports the north in the living and
also tells John the truth but we also
know about this episode two scene is
that it ends with a horn being blown as
you know in the Nights Watch a horn is
blown to warn of someone approaching it
arrangers returning Wilding segregates
or White Walkers in my opinion is
definitely White Walkers and the same
will be the end of episode two if you
have been following image on season a
new select photos you know that there is
a big battle set to take place in season
eight and it's been confirmed to take
place in the third episode of the final
season but the actor who plays the night
king Vladimir Furtick
even though venom fell will not be the
first Castle to be destroyed on his path
he will arrival there by the third
episode which is when this epic battle
for Winterfell begins
verdict let the news slip during a fan
convention Hungary he said a spoiled in
third episode of the last season there's
a battle that the creator's intended to
be historic moment in television almost
the full episode will be about the
battle it will take about one hour it
don't have many Johnston leaks from
episode three but I guess we don't
really need them the night king is
attack in Winterfell John defense
Winterfell all I hope is that John
fights alongside ghost in Aria and ghost
doesn't actually end up sacrificing
himself for John what we do know however
is that winter will not fall it FINA
fell it's better will be a huge defeat
for the living
when FL is on fire the nat king is one
but don't worry Jon Snow and most main
characters will survive as you might
expect this battle valley many dead
check out this image of corpses strewn
across the ground outside the VFL set
and money glass which is just one of a
bunch so just arrives the most dangerous
place to be in episode 3 the place
attacked by 100,000 strong army of the
Dead led by the night king and then in
episode 4 goes to the second most
dangerous place for him place ruled by
Cersei Lannister Johnston will return to
King's Landing in episode 4 for the
first time in the history of the Sirius
Star kit harington was film shooting
something in the brahmic meaning that
jon is headed back to King's Landing at
some point in season 8 and since
director of episode 4 was seen on set we
can say for a fact that this will take
place in episode 4 in this photo
harrington is at the brahmic Smith's at
a tower which is part of the city walls
there's also this mysterious shot of Jon
Snow being escorted along the walls by a
couple of men in black let's move from
the me set a tower to bokor fortress
another impressive structure of the
dubrovnik city walls
Cersei Jon Snow meet one-on-one in
King's Landing
well not exactly one on one a Cersei has
her Queen's Guard and the mountain
around her
he's young coming to play with Cersei
and once again answer to provide a me
chokes
or Jean trying to come in Cersei to let
them all in to make their final stand in
King's Landing there are many
possibilities okay guys this would be
the first part of Justin's fate in
season 8 in the next part I'm bringing
Jon's endgame him riding a dragon named
that to his father
and him being the cause of Circe's
downfall as I believed golden company
will betray Cersei or Jon Snow and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace